baby with a sign language vocabulary of
more than a thousand words and the
ability to understand
thousands more good Koko the western
lowland gorilla was a scientific marvel
and source of wonder for decades
[Music]
Elco who died this week at the age of 46
captured the world's attention not just
because of her ability to communicate
but for her display of human-like
emotions and empathy Koko was born in
captivity in 1971 at the San Francisco
Zoo and began learning sign language at
the age of 1 from dr. penny Patterson as
part of a Stanford research project she
became a sensation back in 1978 as the
subject of a National Geographic cover
story the cover a picture
Coco took of herself in a mirror Coco
would again grace the magazine's cover
in 1985 this time it showed the gentle
giant cradling her pet kitten all ball
Coco rhymed a name for her new king when
the beloved feline died Coco was visibly
upset and seemed to understand the
concept of death
over her lifetime Koko also learned how
to paint play wind instruments and loved
watching movies being a celebrity also
meant KOCO got to bond with other
notable names stars such as Mister
Rogers
can you teach me how to do that Betty
White and even the late Robin Williams
the two hit it off instantly and
famously formed a close friendship